Giá văn thị dởi bó vào tường xấu sĩnh mới, vói nhiều tính hiệu bất đình.
Khí phát chuẩn bị đưa xác quy định lại xuất quan trọng vào ngày 1, 2020.
Theo các trường ra, năm 2018, con trọng làm là dơ đặt ấn tổ của văn,
bởi đà tăng gần lý tổ, sông thị trường có thể giễ dạy sản đối mặt biến động mạnh.
Nếu khi vọng của nhà đủ tư không trung khớt với chính xác của phát,
điểm được truyến nhất trong thống mẹ hai là khả năng tý tục hạo lại xuất.
Phát đã dạng không phải hâm làm điểm phân trăm trong 2 tháng chính và mời.
Và công cố phát watch cho thấy tị trường lính xác khoảng 5-5 trị vình trong khả năng phát sẽ các sạm thêm.
Tuy nhiên, một số trường ra khám nhận định,
ám lực là phát của tự kiến phát tình nhắc sự mấy mức bói xuất,
bà phải bình loa phần trăm để bốn phần trăm.
Hẹn vàng năng sâu dịch quay mức cao khi lục xấu nhiều đồng tìm chủ chốt,
và nếu cầu mạnh tự nhà đủ tư,
dù vầy dù zho điểm đồng hắn hạn vẫn hiện hữu,
nếu phát kai đổi lập trường trình xác, kháng người,
giá văn gí nhận mức ra đậu lượng nơi trung nằm,
sau khi lập định lịch sửa cả thị trường rao ngay và kỳ hả,
tính trung từ đầu năm, giá vả,
lợi tăng khoảng 6-5 phần trăm,
cùng gấu xuân hương đi lên mạnh trung mối cảnh thị trường tăng câu theo dõi xác bự đi tiếp theo của phát.